get ready for your head to explode Joe
Biden thinks his presidency is a
smashing success
there is no quit in America
Nami is single objective we've ever set
out to accomplish that we've failed on
name me one
in all of our history not one
challenge accepted Mr President how
about your border crisis Democrats in
the sanctuary state of New York are
taking shots at one another over who's
to blame for the spiraling migrant
crisis Governor Kathy hokel sending a
scathing 12-page letter that rips New
York city mayor Eric Adam over his
management and failing to properly use
the state's resources but the Democrat
mayor firing right back at her we're
hoping that the governor will put in
place an executive order that would
prevent us from having to go from
location to location to location New
York just cannot continue to take this
flow
okay Greg isn't this what happens when
you declare yourself a sanctuary City in
a sanctuary State and is this the
beginning of the implosion of democrat
lawmakers in New York I don't know I
mean at first I gotta like I gotta
defend Biden he was talking about
history so it wasn't necessary really
about him but that he was using that I
believe as a camouflage against all the
problems which are the Border crime
education mental health us pouring
billions into a war uh while not helping
out the the folks in Hawaii
um and also not uniting the country
which is what he was elected to do and
so far has been doing nothing but divide
him
um but I still find that troubling
because he's not well
I mean I'm sorry that screaming like
that irrationally and you know I never
scream on this show
I usually try to keep myself I try to
keep America calm it's always rational
but he's like there's something going on
there the Democrats can't admit this
openly they need to get him off the
ticket but as long as Kamala is there
that means their choice for VP for now
forces the P to stay put because you
can't get rid of him if she's still
hanging around you know no one wants Joe
for another term much less for four or
five months but the only thing worse is
that chuckling gas bag so it's like they
don't know what to do they're they're in
they're in a tight little corner that's
why Gavin is licking his chops he is oh
yeah all right Dana to name a few of
Biden's accomplishments let's talk about
the Border Afghanistan uh the
polarization cost of living energy
dependence uh and yet in his mind he's
batting a thousand you forgot one other
thing my big my biggest pet peeve right
now is the National Education scores
through K-12 education everything is
down and I'm not saying it's all late at
his feet but covert was a huge problem
they refused to acknowledge it and they
continue to back the teachers unions on
all of that and not and they won't
acknowledge the fact that this is a huge
crisis uh former Secretary of State
Condoleezza Rice when she was on
Newsroom she said these test test scores
in K-12 education are a national
humiliation so one of the things I would
say do you think that you have a
responsibility as president about the
education of America's children I'm just
curious like do you do you think that's
just something that you should ignore
what about all these people we just
talked about who are living on the
street
um that just increases we have an 11
homelessness increase year over year and
that's an under count uh we forgot we
didn't talk about the baby formula issue
in Afghanistan I mean there's plenty of
things a lot of the things I would say
though that he considers accomplishments
like he's passed more bills than Obama
okay great but a lot of his
accomplishments are vulnerabilities and
one of them he admitted this week he
wishes that he had called the inflation
reduction act something else because it
was supposed it wasn't that it was meant
to deal with climate change which we
just talked about but he has a 60
disapproval on climate change and he has
a 36 approval on the economy so his
accomplishments that he as he sees them
are also ver
vulnerabilities if I can get that word
out and you know Charlie I mean when
when Dana talks about the education
system the mess that we're in right now
we are in an embarrassing situation I
mean compared to many other countries
now we've got the uh migrants kids the
illegal aliens are bringing their kids
in and then these local school districts
have to hire teachers who speak not just
Spanish but some people are from Africa
Pakistan India uh what do we do about
that well so like we were saying earlier
so much of it is just basic competence I
mean this is these are real problems
that are going to come about that that
people are going to have to deal with
and it's going to be an impossible
problem as we've seen which is why uh
which is why people like mayor Adams are
now shuttling uh migrants North but I I
also I love your generous uh generosity
yes towards uh Biden talking about the
history and yeah maybe he was kind of
talking about American history but
what's really funny about this is that
um maybe we did everything right before
yes but now all of the problems and I
came up with a long list of them and you
mentioned a lot of them
um all of them happened under his watch
and rather that's why he did the history
thing yeah he added that at the end
because in history but it just goes on
and on and obviously the the unifying
the country was like the really big one
um because that is such a disaster it
turns out that calling half the country
Nazis is probably not a really good way
to do it but it reminds me of Do You
Remember The Simpsons episode where the
town of Springfield declared uh Jimmy
Carter history's monster
we have a new history we have a new
monster
all right Jessica now
um mayor Adams says the costs of uh
paying for these migrants is going to
exceed 12 billion dollars if you're a
New York City taxpayer how do you feel
about that I think the federal
government better Pony up for this and
that it's on them at this point I think
that it's important for us to remain a
sanctuary City there's good reason to be
Sanctuary studies and there are a lot of
Republicans throughout history he
doesn't want to be a sanctuary City
anymore he actually said that no he said
that he wants this dealt with I don't
think that he did he came out and said
he's sorry you're a build-a-wall uh
spend money on the wall no pony up and
pay for the migrants that are here the
federal government
so the people who are here they are
registered in the system through the CCP
one app no well it's pretty far to get
the people who got on the buses right
the governor Abbott's buses Deuces buses
desantises buses whatever those are all
people that are registered in the system
that's how that works you couldn't get
on those buses without it that's right
so we know who they are
they have court dates seven years from
now
some of them yes but
we have a long history of having
undocumented people here who are
tremendous boon not only for our economy
this is always a strong man argument we
love immigrants we just want a system
that works that you can have both why
not for example if you're saying that
the federal has to Pony up what you're
saying is continue to provide the
incentives that have people cross
illegally what we're saying is we love
we need by the way we're not reproducing
we need help we need people I mean
that's the hard truth but the point is
you got to do it through a process and
you know what mayor Adams gave a no-bid
contract to an organization called doc
go it's gave them 432 million dollars
that you're paying for to place all
these illegals in counties of state
which is what they criticize the
Republican Governors for doing and now
they're doing the same thing are they
now inhumane racists and all the other
stuff I didn't use that kind of
terminology I said it was a stunt and
mayor Adams does enjoy a stunt him
himself he's a showman and that's part
of why people like him hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else